what's the best song you ever wrote
seriously out of all the songs i have
you know i don't know if it was funk 49
walk away i don't know all these great
songs what is the greatest song you ever
wrote
eagles wise i co-wrote life in the fast
lane
yeah um solo-wise
probably rocky mountain way yeah what a
[Music]
song
do you still stop and listen to that on
the radio it's on the radio all the time
on uh you know on classic rock stations
do if you hear it will you stop and
listen to it and go man that's a good
[ __ ] record one of the things that
makes it magic is
it's a bunch of guys playing in a room
right that groove you can't do with pro
tool
do you remember any of that process of
writing that great song yeah oh you do
yeah what was the process on that one i
was in colorado
right i was i had left the james gang
i was worried that i might have made a
mistake it's scary
yeah yeah yeah because that was a
successful entity
yeah right yeah we were doing fine why
did you leave
three-piece band i just got saturated
with playing really loud and
and being like a kick-ass guitar
guy right playing through marshalls and
stuff
why you thought on your own you could
what tone it down i was hearing all
these songs like with
a piano and they didn't want that the
other two guys were against it
kinda and also your audience demanded
you be a certain sound
so if you went to a piano you were
afraid the audience would reject so you
just said [ __ ] it i'll leave the whole
thing
yeah and so where so you were scared you
were in colorado
i'm in colorado okay uh
and i have an album done which was uh
the barnstorm album the the first solo
album i did
and i'm on the lawn and
you were mowing the lawn i was mowing
the lawn yeah rock stars mow lawn
i didn't have any words for rocky
mountain way but we had the track done
right and i'm just
dead in the water about this song
what is it about you mean you just hear
music there's no
vocal there's no tune really except
that banana if there were words
i hear where they go but you don't have
the actual words i don't know what they
are so how do they come to you
well i'm on the lawn i look up
and there's the front range of the rocky
mountains
with snow on them in the summer right
and it knocked me back because it was
just beautiful
and i thought well uh
i have committed i'm in colorado it's
too late to regret the james gang
the rocky mountain way is better
than the way i had because the music was
better
and i got the word bam and uh
he's telling us this tells us that
change it every day that's about the
james king's manager
right we don't need the ladies crying
because the story said that's giving up
the regret
of leaving the james gang and i got all
those words all at once and i ran
into the house to write the words down
and the lawnmower kept going
over into the neighbor's yard and
ate the garden it was an expensive song
to write but
oh i got the chills when you tell me
that